yo this video is sponsored by
Squarespace make your next move sup baby
this week on thug notes we jacking in
will ready player one by Ernest Cline
this two here twenty forty and
everything [ __ ] sucks I'm talking
famine poverty energy crisis up the ass
wars I could go on plan to escape this
whacked-out world everybody living a VR
game called the Oasis you can do
anything up in here get your learn on
hustle at a job buy stuff
swinging bang whatever everyone up on
that daily grind when the creator of the
Oasis a tenth bigger ball a name James
Halliday takes that long dirt nap and
drops a video message on all the players
brothers say he hit an easter egg in
oasis and the first cat that man's three
keys that unlocks it gets all his fat
stacks whoo money for the next five
years homies busting ass trying to find
them keys and get on a big-ass
scoreboard
these peeps called Gunter's and they
wild about the 80s and everything
holiday
ain't nobody finds July a ten-year-old
narrator wait step up and crack the
first clue whoa see where he come from
the hood so he's straight obsessed with
getting holidays cash monies one day
wait chilling in Latin class we
recognize the first key might be on this
here school planet so homeboy teleport
to the spot shakes off some traps threat
shop at a mini game and hell yeah he get
that key he tried to book it to the next
spot when he runs it to a famous bunny
named Artemis who way bit hot for since
his balls drunk turns out she's been
trying to beat that minigame for weeks
but just can't hack it way give her a
tip on a low and swings over to the next
clues do pieces through another minigame
like a G and opens up the first gate
where he got a play matthew broderick
and that eighties movie wargames that's
my I did done with that mess he gets the
next clue
soon enough where he got some company on
that scoreboard Artemus his home boy H
and two brothers named Dido and Shoto
are on the Kama some shysters from a
big-ass corporation called IO I start
blowing up Wade's inbox saying they
wanna meet these haters are called sixes
and the only thing on their mind is
making Bank off the Oasis we decide he
want to meet the top dog Sorrento who
offers ways some merit grants to stop
playing for their team when ways say nah
brah I'm straight Sorrento says they
know where he lives and they're gonna
blow it to hell since Wade's real body
is in his hideout he just shake that
hate off then BOOM his auntie's trailer
go up in smoke and a bunch of innocents
get smirked skirt his hell weight harlot
his homies and when he tell her what
went down they all wig out so when he
skips town and lays low by taking a new
name while he's trying to crack the next
clue the sixes try to ice him and he
gets his woman with Artemis but probably
moving a little too fast so Artemis
gotta shut him down
rookie move wait a couple of months go
by and ways doing what I call the
post-breakup hustle work out stay busy
and buy sex dog what else do you need he
ain't no closer to finding a second key
when out of nowhere
Artemis got it with a little help from H
play connects the dots and books it to a
planet where he'd go hard and a game of
pac-man and wins a quarter that was this
boy think this is a little E's day so he
pockets it Flav slides over to another
planet takes down a game and get that
second key it's all good till they get
word that the sixes ghosted Dido and
real-life man that ain't good yo
Sooni boots is the third key it rolls
over to the spot where the easter-egg
gonna be bow spit a whole gang of sixes
it's posted up
outside the castle mm so he comes up
with the plan after getting got by the
police
Wade hacks into the IO I to boost some
scandalous evidence mess with their
shield and then blows that joint he hit
up Artemus showed onh telling them to
bail cuz the Iowa is looking awful in
the real world they all mean the chat
room and conversate about how they're
gonna take down two sixes they need all
the hoods in the Oasis to crew up with
them in this fight so we send out a
message to everybody telling them when
they gonna throw down Ronnie plotting
holidays partner Morrow shows up in a
chat room and say he'd been creepin on
he sent everybody some swanky planes to
haul him to his crib when they ready to
bang out the shield fails and a bunch of
Gunther's and sixes start scrapping the
sixes drop a bomb boom everybody dies
shap wait remember that corner he got
turns out it was an extra life so he
keeps hustling he wrecks another game
and plays King off then that movie with
the coconuts I have to busting through
some other challenges he finally gets
the East Egg holidays character shows up
and say yo reality can be Rossdale but
it's the only place you can find
happiness cuz reality is real you feel
me
Sorrento gets thrown in the clink and
way gonna shed his fat check with his
homies then Wade anonymously guv in the
real world and finally kiss ah yeah
if there's one thing this book always
going on about its escaping from the
horrible Bulls in your life I mean
everybody's lives are so dense that they
all hold up inside a video game the game
don't just give them a different world
but one that let people shine and live
life on easy it ain't just people
getting their marbles off by losing
themselves in another world but also by
losing themselves in the past
everybody in this book always geeked up
about the eighties and [ __ ] from pac-man
and a young Maddie B now I'm not that
one to Monty Python but no Run DMC
Madison Bush if your head always living
in the past
how you gonna create new ideas man how
you supposed to fully live truth is
sometimes by trying to escape one trap
people actually end up creating another
one I'd come and see my rig for what it
was an elaborate contraption for
deceiving my senses to allow me to live
in a world that didn't exist each
component of my rig was a bar in the
cell where I had willingly imprisoned
myself in real life I was nothing but an
antisocial hermit I was just another sad
lost lonely soul wasting his life on a
glorified video game so is this kind of
future technology banging or busted well
on the one hand the Oasis players can
get all the deck knowledge they want I'm
talking free information free schooling
and the ability to conversate we're
homies all over the world but on the
other hand if you don't check yourself
you can end up isolating yourself from
any meaningful connections so is the
Oasis like utopia or a dystopian well to
be real that is ain't so easy though
Oasis give post struggling folks access
to education and jobs since there ain't
none on the outside but that also means
that they ignoring all the mess
happening around them in the real world
which only makes that reality Rakesh
it's like there's a utopia within a
dystopia
you feel me in the real we're all way
they got no friends no Benjamins and
respect but in the Oasis do got a silent
rep a nice cash flow and a lawyer crew I
may just check this one sec way
jabbering about how horrible is things
used to be awesome but now they're kind
of terrifying human civilization is in
decline some people even say is
collapsing let me start talking up is
life like it's all titans luckily I had
access to the Oasis which was like
having an escape hatch into a better
reality it was my playground and my
preschool a magical place where anything
was possible the Oasis is the setting of
all my happiest childhood memories so
let's escape the answer to living in a
jacked-up world is it better to kick
back and live a decent life in a fake
world are beyond a struggling reality
maybe we should spend time caring for
our reality and make it the place to be
rather than just giving up and piecing
out to somewhere else I may be [ __ ]
what's reality anyway I'm going wherever
they got the dank as libraries
he's y'all yo thanks for kicking it with
me and if you're looking to build a fly
website to show off your skills starting
all our business I'll just share your
ideas and creations head on over to
squarespace.com slash Thunder
Squarespace has got easy-to-use tools
for you to quickly and easily make the
websites you want and they've got tons
of a war-winning fly templates to help
you get started you don't need to know
coding or anything and they're giving
all you well-read bowlers 10% off your
first order when you use the offer code
thug notes if that ain't good enough
Squarespace is hook you up with a free
14-day trial so you can see for yourself
just how easy it is so go to
squarespace.com slash thug notes or use
the link in the description below to
sign up today and you'll get a free 14
day trial to test it out be sure to use
the offer code thug notes to give 10%
off your order thanks to Squarespace for
being a homey and sponsoring this video
and we've got lots more videos on the
way so go to our channel page and if you
haven't already make sure to subscribe
while you're there catch y'all next time
ace